hypermedia do you remember when we were
talking about websites we said that they
were all designed in a particular
language right namely HTML HTML is
remember that what did it stand for
right the age stood by I thought Chifa
text em for markup Elfa language say
sure it was a way of formatting data
that's the marker part right and allowed
people to what was built into it was
being able to get to different content
through the content you're looking at so
you could click on leagues and pictures
and it would take you to different
things okay now here's the thing the
Internet as we know it right you know
any website that you go to it's all
hypertext is he some data here right
lots and lots of useful dialog but it's
not very structured right it's almost
the opposite of a database database is
well defined fields I know the same
things that all the same all the
different things I've got and very
defined records highly structured hyper
media is the opposite and so this is
where my statement comes from mm-hmm
searching through a hyper media system
like say the Internet is particularly
challenging when compared to a database
any kind of database one figure out or
look at SQL queries before right if
you've got the right fields you know
what you're after the right conditions
you can just run it through it'll get
everything that's relevant to your
search but with five media or something
like that in it there's no fields there
no consistent things that you can search
for right
there's no what's this webpage about
field right well how useful is this
webpage there's no actual feel built
into all these different type of media
systems that we're looking at so it's
challenge to try and search through this
but it's particularly rewarding why why
is it particularly running as such
detail what kinds of things do you guys
search for on the Internet
maybe I shouldn't ask that good [ __ ]
I'm trying to I'm trying to I'm trying
to waste time trying to find something
funny trying to find something
interesting I'm trying to find something
relevant news all these kinds of things
right in the real world really useful
information isn't put into nice neat
holes like a Donovan's in the real world
it's out there in caca media okay sir
how do we search through how do we get
out though all the meaningful stuff out
of all of these useless meaningless
stuff well there are two main solutions
in this one which we'll talk about first
is kind of ancient and it's fallen out
of use and I'm gonna ask you guys later
on why that is the other one is kind of
taken over so let's look at these in
turn now we start with the second one a
search engine because I think you're
more familiar with it userland more
day-to-day basis what is a search engine
what is a search engine so so we're
thinking for instance right in fact you
know these guys are served synonymous
with the search engine and searching
that they're actually in the dictionary
now right then you can root or something
what's the idea
right it's a piece of software it's a
piece of software that knows or can work
out how relevant or how useful are
different webpages
Scott it's got rules to try and
determine that and because it's a piece
of software it's automatic it was
designed by humans right but it doesn't
require human intervention to keep on
going okay I thought a search engine is
now by contrast a web directory as
opposed to be an automatic piece of
software it's a manual but as in it's
not by some by humans by hand it's a
manual what we call a curated collection
you know what curator does where do you
hear about curators in a museum right
stuffed is Oren and Anne
gathering right things are hand-picked
they're selected they're chosen a queen
a very strict criteria so under a red
tractor you've got someone who really
knows this stuff and they're picking
things out by hand that's all you've
learn manual okay now let me show you an
example this Yahoo
made it start as a web directory and you
can still find the web directory pod
that dir for directory yahoo.com
what are we looking at okay what you've
got is a whole set of categories okay
and if we pick one say business and
economy okay underneath each category
you've got subcategories for things that
people are interested in so we look the
business let's go into war and
underneath here you can see the people
that Yahoo the employees have by hand
picked out these three websites as you
know right at the top of the list for
the most useful websites in this
category okay now you can obviously go
to any other category and find different
kinds of websites lists of websites
useful websites that are ranked in
different ways or corners now let's
think about this let's think that some
advantages or disadvantages in these
let's think about the web directory
what's the big disadvantage that leaps
out of you for getting information out
of the internet like this what you guys
reckon okay good
you got bias right so suppose I'm at
Yahoo employee and I've I just happened
to have made a website about you know
more okay some part of it I'm gonna be
strongly disposed or maybe not me
maybe a friend right maybe you know
you'd be really suss if you got to this
section and at the very top record you
know Jack Yang's long web sites really
you know how did he get up there maybe
you had a friend who's biased is the
first thing it's possible secondly you
go back for instance you have a look at
all these categories just have a look at
these numbers here of how many websites
are underneath there
say for instance under our classifiers
you've got two thousand five hundred
forty nine different web sites now how
many web sites could you look up
in a day and go through and think about
them say oh this is good this is bad in
order to come up with 2,000 popular for
none it's up all Lots its kid skied he's
gonna take you from Revit actually do
this right so just like all the manual
processes this is a very very
time-consuming process okay number one
bias number two time-consuming number
three the Internet is not a static place
it's changing all the time right I don't
know if you guys have ever tried to find
directions to somewhere and you've been
in the car and you've looked up the not
web directory you look up the street
directory right and the place you're
going is like some relatively new suburb
and you're going to find it and there's
just like a gray spot the hair just
doesn't exist okay well you're in a
place that you're familiar with and you
look at the street directory and it's
been changed roads that used to go one
way now go another way or there's a
roundabout summer or any traffic light
so the problem of when directories since
they're curated manually they don't
change as the internet changes right so
they have a lot of trouble stay
up-to-date it takes a lot of manpower to
actually make that happen so you can see
section is have some advantages over web
directories and that's largely why
search engines are now become so much
more successful let's just finish I'm
saying why do you think web directories
were worthwhile in the first place and
are still worthwhile what advantages do
they have do they possess over search
engines yeah Jack ok good so this search
engine rank it's a piece of software
it's automatic follows rules and
therefore those rules can be manipulated
right if I know the rules well in fact
there's a whole industry called search
engine optimization which marketers
focus on which is all about helping
businesses take advantage of this system
and get their company website up the top
of the results because that's really
really that's a great way to get traffic
right if your websites always one of the
first to results so search engines can
get gamed right it's a system you can
get manipulated ok
and in the same way a web directory
right because the human being when you
go to this you can know it's reliable
right because another human being
assuming the website sites are still
there that if for a human being has
looked at it said yeah this is good
where is the search engines right
something could slip through this right
and it might not actually be a useful
result in might be just total rubbish
might be gibberish okay it might not
even be in your language but it just
made it through okay does that make
sense so for all of the advantages of
such answers have been our perfect web
directories still have mini strengths